je vous voyais l'agira aux propos de
bernard henri lévy qui avait l'air
nouveau nom c'est massa cesser les
propos il devait d'abord n'y a pas que
lui qui est qui et qui utilise cette
rhétorique aujourd'hui on a parlé des
médias américains tout à l'heure non moi
je
suis navré quand j'entends ce genre de
discours parce que moi ça fait 20 ans
que je couvre les conflits dans le monde
entier l'irak la syrie comment le mali
la libye en particulier et je vois une
chose c'est qu'à chaque fois 7 cette
rhétorique existe elle elle et elle y
est avancé par des intellectuels bien
pensants qui pensent que d'aller à la
guerre ça va solutionner les choses je
prend exactement
à des fins la période de 20 ans puisque
les talibans viennent de reprendre le
pouvoir vingt ans après en avoir été
chassés et la première de ces guerres de
ce type ça a été larguée nice temps on
se rend compte finalement donc
l'afghanistan on y est allé pour vingt
ans plus tard redonner les clés à ce que
on avait chassé l'irak on a détruit
l'irak avec ce qu'a dit fort justement
le l'ambassadeur russe à l'onu des
mensonges ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui des
mensonges ceux qui ont proféré qui ont
utilisé ces mensonges en particulier
georges bush colin powell lui même
donald rumsfeld maintenant ils n'ont
jamais été inquiétés par la justice
c'est quand même une guerre qui a foutu
en l'air le moyen-orient et qui a laissé
un pays l'irak que je connais très bien
en lambeaux jeu je parle aussi de la
libye où là ce n'est pas des mensonges
mais ça a été une résolution de l'onu
savait qui était la résolution 1973 qui
a qui avait pour but de protéger les
populations civiles on est allé jusqu'à
la chute de kadhafi le même kadhafi dont
on s'est contenté pendant trente ans
sans que cela ne pose de problème donc
tout à coup cette rhétorique qui dit
attention si on n'intervient pas c'est
une catastrophe
et en plus entendre parler de paix en
temps de dire oui ça va amener la paix
le risque que ce que ça a eu que vous
savez ce qui va se passer s'il ya une
guerre il va se passer c'est que
l'ukraine va être le champ de bataille
et on ne craignent ni les séparatistes
de l'est ni les ukrainiens n'ont envie
de voir cette guerre je regardais
aujourd'hui des témoignages justement à
des confrères de cnn d'une femme qui vit
côté ukrainien très proche de la ligne
de front et dit déjà la guerre de 2014 a
été la pire chose qui m'est arrivé dans
ma vie donc il ya des gens qui sont sur
place s'ils vont payer les conséquences
de cette intervention il y aura pas de
vainqueur la russie va pas être des
fêtes et l'ukraine si elle aidé par
l'otan va se maintenir donc il va y
avoir une situation épouvantable avec
une catastrophe et comment voulez-vous
que eu la paix sorte de ça puisque les
quatre derniers conflits que j'ai
précédemment cités ont terminé par les
cds pays absolument anéanti jeu j'ai
oublié de dire pour la libye une des
conséquences de la libye c'est ce qui se
passe au manu aujourd'hui également donc
attention aussi aux guerres qui ont des
effets de ricochet on ne s'interroge
jamais sur ces gars là on laisse passer
et la fois deux suivants et bien on
entend toujours cette petite musique de
il faut intervenir à tout prix sinon
c'est la fin du monde merci beaucoup
régisseur